hello and welcome to pi data global 2021
my name is natalie and i'm very happy to
be here and be your host for this
session i would like now to and to
welcome stravos papa
papa
can you please do you mind
yes
that was a good attempt
and he will talk about tau dp and the
new data economics prior to founding tau
db in february 2017 dr papadopoulos was
a senior research scientist at the intel
parallel computing lab and the member of
the intel science and technology center
for big data at mit sea sale for three
years he also spent about two years as a
visiting assistant professor at the
department of computer science and
engineering of the hong kong ust and
with that i'll give to florida's travels
thank you so much for joining us today
thank you natalie uh thank you everyone
for for attending um so i'm going to
share my screen
um for the presentation
so
i'm going to talk
about a topic that is not as technical
as pretty much every other
single presentation and webinar we have
given the company our company is
extremely technical
this is a presentation that i thought i
would give for the entire data community
because i think these these issues
should concern
everybody and especially the pi data
community um and then at the end i'm
going to present the company so i'm
going to do it in reverse first i'm
going to talk about some more general
stuff and then i'm going to tell you
what we do talk about how we are
addressing these issues
okay so when when i talk about data
economics i mean effectively three
things in the context of my my
presentation
first uh the production of the data and
specifically the format the data is
produced in and where it goes where is
it stored this is
what we should be focusing on when it
comes to production that affects data
management and data computations down
the road the second thing is
distribution
so who has access to the data
what is the means of the access and how
can we make money out of the data and
compute because there are a lot of
organizations that are monetizing their
data
and finally how do we consume the data
what tools
and where does the computation happen so
these are the data economics at least in
my mind in this presentation
so what is the problem with the entire
community this is holistic guys it's
it's not about a single vertical it's
across the verticals across the domains
and some domains are extremely different
or at least seemingly different they're
suffering from exactly the same problems
so the problem is that all data
management solutions all tools focus on
consumption
that's it like predominantly when we
try to create solutions we focus on
consuming the data and the computations
the computations how scalable they are
where do they run the cloud on prem so
this is the problem that most of the
solutions at least i know especially
from the database domain
they focus only on this and they
completely completely ignore the other
two
so at the general level the problem is
that
this
leads to the data being produced in
inefficient formats only because
production is not on the radar for us
somebody produces the data in some
different formats and then we're
trying to wrangle the data into our
format or into some processable format
so that we do the analytics most formats
are domain specific the domains don't
talk to each other the bioinformatician
does not talk to an earth observation
scientist this creates a lot of problems
i'm going to explain a couple in a bit
the distribution uh and especially
issues around sharing collaboration are
an afterthought
this is not what the databases are
architected around usually they try to
incorporate features later
most tools are domain specific again
each domain works kind of separately on
their own data with their own tools and
they're missing out on more generic
tools in data science for example or in
databases that could be a great fit for
them
and a lot of etl is involved a lot of
conversion transformation copying of
data from one format to another in order
to make you know meaningful analysis on
the data so that's the the general
problem i'll give you a couple of
examples to make my case
for example genomics so genomics data
comes in these weird formats called
fastq bam and dcf the predominant
formats
these are produced by the sequencers
then this data is usually stored in some
cloud buckets or ftp servers you will be
surprised
and
some of the solutions are like dropbox
with hipaa compliance so they're file
managers because they work on files
they're not databases
they they have not incorporated database
solutions yet
and the analysis is done with domain
specific tools like pcf tools and jdk
not with the general data science tools
that you would see at pi data for
example
another application is marine traffic so
ais data ship locations on on the map
the data is in csv files
storage in cloud packets distributed and
sold this data can be sold as files so
you see the correlation kind of
and the analysis and visualization is
done with specific tools domain specific
tools like gis
finance and specifically historical data
um data in text files
storage in cloud packets distributed and
sold as files
you see you see the pattern here and how
different these domains are they suffer
from exactly the same problems
and the analysis with some database or
some data science tools these are a
little bit more general i would have to
say and some domain specific tools too
and then lidar again yet another domain
the data is in last files domain
specific storage in cloud packets
distributors files with metadata and
analysis visualization visualization
with
gis tools so you see the pattern is
there and i'm going to elaborate on the
problems a little bit
so let's take each problem one by one
and understand what the actual issue is
so for the production problem again
there are some sources the you know the
organizations that are producing the
data in isolation from those that will
consume the data
and the data is in the formats that they
choose
they choose the formats they don't care
about what kind of analysis you're going
to use because they they own the data
they own the format they choose
usually a legacy format it's usually
something that was you know chosen ad
hoc
50 years ago and they continue to use
the same thing
then this is dumped somewhere because
it's a file so usually now
some object store on the cloud which is
cheap because this is a lot of data
or some kind of a file manager
then there is a lot of etl because that
format is not useful so there has to be
some etl
and then you know the users create their
own analytics infrastructure
in order to consume the data so what is
the problem the problem first is the etl
it's a big bottleneck to try to convert
petabytes of data in your format only to
be able to slice the data
and also
this analytics infrastructure because
the format is custom and because there
is no holistic approach
you build it on your own
you will be surprised how many different
institutions are building the same
infrastructure but in different ways
custom and in-house and this is costly
and time-consuming for the organization
the organization's ip is not
in building the infrastructure is in
what comes through the insights from the
analytics so these are the problems
created by producing the data in the
wrong format
in terms of distribution there are two
problems
let's take the first one again the data
always in some custom format
and
this goes into some bucket or some
marketplace there is an advent of
marketplaces uh in the past couple of
years so they store the files and they
are the distributors of the files
and then
there's an organization they need to
take the file the files download wrangle
build infrastructure so store the data
in their own buckets in their own
infrastructure build their own tools and
this happens across n organizations
there are a thousand organizations using
the same files they will do that a
thousand times for example there is an
ais company you know distributing their
csv files
every single organization using those
files will have to download the files or
wrangle in some more meaningful format
and create an infrastructure for queries
they do the same thing
so the problem is here there is a lot of
reinvention
and this is again very very costly only
because you know the organization's
distributing the data they're
distributing files they're not
distributing an analytics infrastructure
the second problem is when
some organizations the data owners
again they they
gather the files where they're producing
the files but now they are building
something more okay they're building
their own infrastructure so they're
saying okay we're gonna curate for
example financial data and we will build
an actual infrastructure
right to
sell the data and distribute this data
and then the users just consume the data
just queries no more infrastructure just
queries so this is moving towards the
right direction but here are the plot
the problems
the data owner burst the cost
right if there is a financial duration
company that distributes the curated
data and they want to build
infrastructure they will have to pay for
it they will have to build it they will
have to pay for it and they will have to
pay for all the users using this
infrastructure and these economics are
wrong right they are wrong for for those
data owners to the point that the data
owners go back to the previous slide
which means they distribute the data in
files in buckets
right that's the problem this is
difficult to pull off and also if there
are a thousand
different data owners from a thousand
different domains they need to build the
same infrastructure
to service their data because the data
is not as
different as you might think that it is
i'm going to get back to this in a bit
and finally the consumption problem
is that again
tons of files different formats
you put them in some storage bucket or
some server
and then each of the groups within the
organization so now suppose that this is
within your the same organization
they have to take the data from whatever
form your stock you know the
organization is storing the data and use
any tool could be python it could be
spark it could be dust whatever they
want but then if there is another group
they will have to again
download copy the data wrangle the data
and use another tool
only because the tools
cannot coordinate on the same data and
only because this infrastructure the
data lake right that is being promoted
is just a file manager and if it is a
file manager and the organization has a
hundred groups with a hundred different
tools they will have to build the same
micro infra within the organization
again you cannot imagine how many people
we've seen doing this how many
organizations we have we have even
talked to groups in the same
organization that don't talk to each
other and they have built different
micro infrastructures so the problem is
again is here this is inefficient and
costly and there is a lot of reinvention
as well and we're talking about the same
data right like infrastructures that
access the same data
so
how do we solve this problem and again
this is for the community for anybody
working on this
on this topic and again our our message
here is
um approach
data economics holistically and across
the domains don't think only about
genomics don't think only about earth
observation
holistically right there has to be there
have to be so many similarities that we
need to approach this holistically so
here's a proposal and then i'm going to
tell you how to be is actually solving
this how tall is an instance obviously
of this solution
so first of all
we need to depart from the formats folks
we need to build something we need to
produce the data directly
into something that is analysis ready
it's something that is universal and by
universal we mean that it can capture
all data types
and all tools will be able to consume
efficiently so a universal format
for all data
second we need the data management
platform again universal if it works on
a universal format we can build a single
platform a single whether it is genomics
or geospatial a single platform that
addresses this on the same data model on
the same data model and this can do
pretty much the governance the
distribution the analytics everything
and then this will enable
any number of users any number of
organizations to use any tool with any
scale without building infrastructure so
the benefits are clear
no etl and copies anymore there is a
single copy of the data in an analysis
ready wave so there is no need to render
this anymore you just slice it
the second is that one infrastructure
any back-end any scale
this has to be part of the data
management platform that's its job
then unified governance you build one
authentication mechanism one access
control mechanism even one marketplace
for all these applications for all these
data types
and again a common across all and again
i'm going to tell you exactly how you
can pull this off in the next slides and
the marketplace that i mentioned so this
is a solution this is how it should look
like it addresses
everything from production to the
universal format to distribution the
unified governance to consumption with
any tool that's that's a holy grail
so how did we solve it
first
we chose multi-dimensional arrays
as the universal format
and it is universal i'm going to show
this to you in the next slide
we were able to capture
tens of applications already and there
are so many other others waiting just
with this format very very efficiently
second we built the platform we built a
single platform with all the benefits
that that i mentioned in the previous
slide on arrays since we unified the
model we were able to build a unified
infrastructure
and then we have
extreme interoperability with all tools
anything in the in the pi data ecosystem
so that there is no copying
all with zero copy techniques
so the benefits again multi-dimensional
arrays for the universal format you have
the governance and collaboration here
the built-in marketplace is here in the
pay-as-you-go manner
the cost is shifted to the consumers
that's how tildebig works polyb
manages all the infrastructure at crazy
scale if you're a data owner you just
put the data in the tag be format you
register your data with the platform and
then you may have millions of users
running on the talib infrastructure
serverless
very easily without the data owner
paying a single dollar for
infrastructure
that's the way we solve this problem we
ship the code we crowdsource the cost of
distribution rather than forcing the
data owners to build the infrastructures
to serve their data
and we do it we take it to to the
extreme you can share data you can share
code you can sell data and you can sell
code
runable code so these are aspects of
that b that will be left to a different
presentation but i'm just giving you an
idea of an instantiation of a solution
to this data economics problem
so a few more details now about ldb and
then i'm going to conclude we will have
time for questions so this is how the
the multi-dimensional array data model
looks like
there are two flavors dense and sparse
for those that have used
structures like this type unifies this
it's not like hdf5 or zar it has the
same features and then some and
especially
a lot of work on the sparsity right we
we capture sparse data extremely
efficiently
again we have separate webinars for that
if you want to look into the format
we're going to look into uh into the
storage engine we have everything online
we have a lot of materials regarding the
universal platform the universal
database here's how we build it uh
imagine at the bottom any back end
talib is not just cloud it is cloud
native but it's not cloud only you can
use it anywhere you can use it on the
laptop you can use it on your on-prem
infrastructure it is not bound to a
particular particular cloud vendor
then at the very top think of anything
we have seven apis growing we have
integrations with spark dusk mariadb
pres.three no you just name it and if if
there is a popular package popular
library that our users and customers are
using and they're going integration with
we integrate very very efficiently with
zero copy techniques and everything and
we have two offerings to solve this
problem
first it's about the format and the
storage engine of the format it's called
alibi embedded it's a library it's not a
server
you can find it on github over here and
this deals with everything arranged the
format versioning time traveling it has
a lot of sophistication just in the open
source and this will always be open
source
and then the actual platform we call it
ldp cloud it works both as sas as well
as on-prem and this is what adds
more to the storage which is the
authentication access control serverless
sql user defined function task graphs
again a lot of sophistication a lot of
features but again the
solving the problem that i mentioned in
the previous in the previous slide
so that's it about the technology again
i i promise that i'm going to keep it
high level and i'm not going to get too
technical but all the technical
materials are online and i'm going to
conclude with a few words about who we
are and how to find us and everything so
talib got spun out of uh a research
project that uh that i have built at
interlabs and mit between 2014 and 2017
uh it has deep roots at the intersection
of high performance computing because of
intel
databases because of the database group
that mit i was working with and data
science because contrary to others i
talked to a lot of scientists across
pretty much every domain you can think
of and this is what gave rise to the
universality of child db
um we're well capitalized we've raised
some we're busy back we have some very
important
vc firms supporting us uh currently
we're 14 growing we're hiring constantly
and we have a lot of traction across
multiple domains from telecoms to
hospitals to to farmers and so on so
forth
so with that i would like to thank you
so much for the opportunity uh please
know that we are hiring uh apply if you
found this interesting and or intriguing
and i'm happy to answer any questions
so we have a question from mike
um so just how db arrays work with numpy
arrays in some way
yeah absolutely so we so tile db
embedded the storage engine
is a c plus plus library but we have a
python api it's called ldb dash pi you
can find it on github you can find
everything on github and this has tight
integration with both numpy and pandas
when i say
tight i mean
we bring the data into numpy and pandas
with zero copy techniques so it's as
fast as it gets you're gonna get in
python the same performance you get in c
plus plus
thank you very much you can always find
us by browsing our website
at talib.com you will find all the
materials there we're very accessible we
have a slack community
you can join it and you can ask
questions and you can find me also on
the pi data global
slack community channel if you have more
questions if you're going to set up
meetings we're very open to that thank
you stravis for your talk and being part
of pi data global 2021
thank you bye